einen wunderschönen guten abend hier aus
wien schönen guten abend alexander
schallenberg neuer kanzler kann man
herzlichen glückwunsch sagen oder eher
nicht aber es kam sehr überraschend wir
haben natürlich eine wilde phase in den
letzten tagen in der österreichischen
innenpolitik und ich gehe dieses amt des
bundeskanzlers republik österreich mit
großer ehrfurcht und respekt an ich hab
es nicht gewünscht und habe es auch
nicht erwartet aber es ist eine enorme
verantwortungsvolle aufgabe und ich
glaube dass wesentliche jetzt ist einmal
das schiff sozusagen mit den ruhige
gewässer zu bringen scheint betrugs und
korruptionsvorwürfe manipulierte umfrage
nur schlaf chat nachrichten jetzt sogar
die festnahme einer meinungsforscherin
wie erklären sie eigentlich staats und
regierungschefs wenn diese jetzt
antworten wenn sie die an anrufen was
hier los ist in österreich ganz auch für
mich habe als außenminister schon in den
letzten monaten wurde ich nie mit fragen
zu diesen themen befasst
ich sehe da ich erwarte dass ein ich
auch jetzt nicht wir haben eine
funktionierende rechtsstaat ich vertraue
auf die justiz wenn es etwas aufzuklären
gibt wird es aufgeklärt werden in diesem
land und das wird doch das ist also
spielen wir das nur durch ich bin jetzt
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel ruft sie
an und fragt was ist in österreich los
wäre er jetzt ich werde jetzt nicht ganz
auf meine gespräche die ich mit anderen
staats und regierungschefs würden werde
hier von ihnen nachvollziehen ich wurde
wie gesagt in der vergangenheit darauf
angesprochen aber was kann jetzt ja
passieren weil österreich ist in den
weltnachrichten mit diesem betrugs und
grob songs wurden und dann werde ich
ganz klar sagen dass dort wo eine
aufklärung erfolgen wirklich erwartet
dass sie rasch funktioniert und dass
hier die justiz arbeiten wird und das
hat der vergangenheit bewiesen wir haben
einen funktionierenden rechtsstaat wir
würden nicht den geringsten zweifel
und ich persönlich habe ja auch schon am
montag gesagt dass ich persönlich der
meinung bin dass die strafrechtlichen
vorwürfe an den ehemaligen
bundeskanzlers parteiobmann am programm
sebastian kurz dass die sich erwarte ich
in luft auflösen was macht sie denn
eigentlich so sicher haben sie diese
hunderten seiten selbst gelesen ja ich
hab natürlich
das gelesen und seiten sich kenne ihn
seit vielen vielen jahren
und es gab ja schon gestern zum beispiel
strafrechtsprofessor der selber gesagt
hat dass da die suppe einige dass die
super dünn ist also ich habe großes
vertrauen was wichtig ist jetzt dass wir
auch rasch zur aufklärung kommen allein
wenn es gab eine festnahme einer
meinungsforscherin die für ihre partei
sie sind auch mitglied der svp diesen
manipulierten umfragen angefertigt haben
soll das sind doch schwerwiegende
vorbild bewiesen die nvp das so
überstehen es gerade läuft das sind
natürlich vorwürfe aber noch einmal die
müssen aufgeklärt werden jetzt gibt es
ermittlungen nicht jede ermittlung führt
seine anklage nicht die anklage führt zu
einer verurteilung ist da noch
rechtliche dinge aus ihrer sicht den
vorfällen ja es geht lassen wir mal
sozusagen die justiz einfach arbeiten
und ich habe vertrauen dass sie uns die
zur ihre arbeit machen wird treten sie
als kanzler zurück wenn es eine anklage
oder sogar einen schuldspruch gegen
sebastian kurz geben sollte also ganz
offen ich wurde am montag angelobt als
bundeskanzler republik österreich und
ich werde dieses amt nach bestem wissen
und gewissen erfüllen wie das mit mir
zusammen hängt das sehe ich jetzt
unmittelbar nicht mein auftrag ist
dieses substanzielle regierungsprogramm
das wir haben wir haben eine sehr
außergewöhnliche situation dass mitten
in der legislaturperiode sozusagen ein
wechsel im bundeskanzleramt stattfindet
jetzt geht es mal ruhe reinzubringen und
wir werden die das substanzielle
regierungsprogramm schritt für schritt
umsetzen und wir haben uns darauf
geeinigt in dieser kollektion dass wir
diese substanz arbeit doch leisten
wollen können sie herrn schmidt
persönlich das ist ja derjenige der
tausende hunderttausende
chat-nachrichten ja in seiner box hatte
oder ein handy hatte die jetzt
ausgewertet werden haben sie man erst in
betrieb ich kenne ihn persönlich will
wir haben vor circa acht jahren haben
wir ja mal im selben team gearbeitet
seitdem haben wir noch einen sehr sehr
losen kontakt aber ja ich kenne im
parlament haben sie diese 100
vierseitige hausdurchsuchung die davon
der neo scheffeln innenbereich wurde
einfach auf den boden geworfen das wird
so ein bisschen als wird sich das gar
nicht interessieren was dagegen kurz und
seiner vertrauten also ich habe es nicht
auf den boden geworfen und am boden
gelegt es wurde mir auf der
regierungsbank von mir hingelegt ist
wird klar das ist dort liege das kann
ich hab's da helfen wurden gelegt ich
habe dann gemerkt bei der rückkehr aus
dem parlament dass das eine gewisse
aufregung erzeugt und da habe ich mich
entschuldigt wird das war keine sekunde
von mir bei absicht intendiert
despektierlich gegenüber die justiz zu
sein oder gegenüber der opposition im
parlament
das war einfach ein akt wenn man mir auf
einen sitzplatz etwas hinlegt sondern
das weg gelegt aber trotzdem habe ich
den eindruck und auch dadurch dass sie
sich festgelegt haben dass diese
vorwürfe falsch seien dass sie sagen gut
das interessiert mich eigentlich nicht
so richtig was da passiert das ist
nochmal darüber sprechen was dort hin
und her geschrieben wurde also da wurde
zwischen vertrauten von sebastian kurz
zusammen mit diesem umfrageinstitut ganz
konkret offenbar die zahlen fingiert da
wurden aufträge gegeben an den miet an
die medien es geht um korruption und
bestechung wenn sie sagen sie haben
diese 104 seiten oder auch diese
weiteren dokumente gelesen was ist ihnen
durch den kopf gegangen als diese
nachrichten gelesen haben und ich glaube
man muss oft klar unterscheiden das gibt
es sozusagen den strafrechtlich
relevanten teil wo ich eben wie gesagt
vertraue darauf dass die justiz arbeitet
ich glaube ich habe auch eine rasche
aufklärung und dann gibt es sozusagen
denn die tonalität die art des umgangs
die tonart das ist natürlich nicht
sozusagen die tonalität die man pflegen
sollte man muss aber auch in rechnung
stellen das sind nachrichten interner
natur so ähnlich wie ein brief
jeder der hier sozial moralische urteil
sollte mal sein gewissen erforschen ob
er nie in seinem leben vielleicht in
einer witzigen verhandlungen oder eine
redaktionssitzung man sms geschickt hat
dir vielleicht so nicht gerne in der
öffentlichkeit sehen wie sehr schaden
diese ermittlung dem image österreichs
ich habe im ausland noch nie eine
situation gehabt wo mich jemand damit
konfrontiert mich fragt ich war doch
immerhin jetzt sein halbjahre außer und
europaminister die situation ist nie
aufgekommen also ich kann ja für sich an
das image es ist völlig unbeschädigt wir
haben einen funktionierenden rechtsstaat
also es gibt in allen staaten immer
wieder situationen wie aufkommen wir
sollten auch in die institutionen
vertrauen ich habe großes großes
vertrauen der österreichischen
institutionen in das system sozusagen
der gewaltenteilung checks und balances
und das wird doch funktionieren und
ihres präsident hat sie bereits für die
respektlosigkeiten entschuldigt werden
sie das auch noch tun also ganz offen
ich bin jetzt vor knapp 48 stunden ein
gelobt worden dass bundeskasse dieser
republik und meine auftrag ist es diese
arbeit in der regierung vorzuführen das
werde ich auch tun ich sehe jetzt keinen
unmittelbaren bedarf dass ich mich
persönlich als bundeskanzler für etwas
entschuldigen noch einmal ich glaube
dort wo aufklärung notwendig ist soll
sie geschehen soll sie rasch geschehen
lassen sie uns über die inserate politik
sprechen in österreich was da seit
vielen vielen jahren an der tagesordnung
ist dass politische parteien dass
ministerien insbesondere in
boulevardzeitungen anzeigen schalten in
großer und intensiver form braucht es
eine komplette neuordnung dieser
inseraten politik also ganz offen ich
stehe natürlich offen für alle gespräche
hatte bis jetzt noch nicht die
gelegenheit dazu ich bin also knapp 48
stunden bundeskanzler ich glaube es gibt
keine demokratie wo das perfekt läuft
ich kenne ähnliche diskussion dass allen
staaten zwischen der europäischen union
und das ließ das noch nicht dass man er
nennt aber sozusagen die frage wie
funktioniert die öffentliche die
förderung von öffentlichen sendern oder
fund von von medien haben sie besonders
politiker die besonders viele inserate
in boulevard zeitungen geschaltet haben
besonders freundliche berichterstattung
bekommen haben weil tagesordnung ist
also ganz offen ich habe das sind diese
form man könnte es umgekehrt formulieren
es gab ja bekannte bundeskanzlerin
publik die im ruf standen besonders eng
mit war sozusagen zusammenzuarbeiten und
auch zu inserieren und die gibt es schon
nicht mehr wenn ich einen bundeskanzler
faymann denke also hält also ich habe
hin und wurde warten bearbeitet die
rechnung die rechnung 1 dass ein
politiker
selbstverständlich mit medien
zusammenarbeit und natürlich notabene
mit jenen medien die eine große
reichweite haben ich meine sie sitzen
hier vertreter einer solchen medias aus
deutschland bei uns sind aber nicht
verraten korruption das ist der
unterschied zu österreich offenbar und
dieses wort inseraten produktion wird ja
immer wieder genannt auch schon seit
vielen vielen jahren haben sie das
system an sich das gefühl dass das
system kaputt ist dass es eine reform
braucht also ganz offen allein der
begriff inseraten korruption kann ich
jetzt nicht so stehen lassen das würden
nehmen sie etwas vorweg wenn es irgendwo
solche staatlich aufzuklären ist dann
wird das erfolgen wir haben ein system
das sub gewachsen die seit jahren wenn
es eine diskussionsbedarf gibt und ich
weiß auch dass es da verschiedene
stimmen gibt auch vom koalitionspartner
stehe ich natürlich offen für
diskussionen
ich werde mich aber nicht jetzt nach
zwei tagen im amt schon diesbezüglich
festlegen lassen wir uns über ihre
arbeit jetzt als kanzler sprechen hier
und im kanzleramt entfernt wo bis
vorgestern bis samstag sebastian kurz zu
hause war ist die sap zentrale nur rund
800 meter entfernt wie unabhängig können
sie eigentlich als kanzler arbeiten wenn
sebastian kurz da drüben wir jetzt
eigentlich eine regierungszentrale
eingerichtet also zwei punkte dazu
bundesverfassungsgericht bundeskanzlers
ganz klar ich wurde am montag zum
bundeskanzler angelobt und ich habe eine
bewährte regierungsmannschaft zusammen
arbeiten werde aber etwas in der
demokratie auch ganz klar wir sind ja
nicht in der regierung sozusagen im
spiel der freien politischen kräfte es
gibt eine koalition eine aufrechte
koalition der vp der christlich sozialen
und der grünen in diesem land wir sind
überein gekommen dass wir diese
koalition fortführen werden und da ist
es völlig normal dass man sich mit dem
klub im parlament das heißt bei uns oder
eben mit der partei ab spricht das ist
man wir sind sozusagen nicht frei
schwebend in dieser branche politische
zielrichtung vor sich oder sowas dann
kurz wir werden uns sehr einen
absprechen ich in meiner rolle man hat
ja manchmal unterschiedliche meinung zu
politischen themen
deswegen braucht es abstimmung ganz
offen wir arbeiten seit jahren schon
zusammen sebastian kurz aber in
unterschiedlichen rollen verteilung da
war das ist aber ich weiß außenministern
musste da auch nicht irgendwie
regelmäßig mit dem reden weil wir haben
einen sehr starken konsens und
übereinstimmung dass politische fragen
betrifft aber selbstverständlich so wird
es in allen anderen regierungen ende
repräsentativen demokratie in der fall
ist werden wir uns abstimmen ich habe
meine rolle das wort
wenn es sozusagen geht um rolle der
regierungsarbeit ich bin als bundeskasse
dieser republik angelobt ich habe die
verantwortung gegenüber dem parlament
und dem volk unter diese verantwortung
werde ich auch wahrnehmen es gibt
weiterhin heftige kritik an sebastian
kurz auch von landeshauptmann in der vp
und auch stimmen die in die richtung
gehen und sagen eigentlich reicht das
noch nicht an konnte grenzen weil dort
zitat würde man ein sittenbild erkennen
in der vp wie sehen sie seine rolle
jetzt als europäischer wie lange kann er
das übernehmen also eigentlich steht
überhaupt nicht zur frage vor wenigen
wochen wurde noch mit 99 4 prozent zu so
genannten ergebnis zum parteiobmann
wieder bestätigt gerade letzten montag
also vorher gäste mit 100 prozent der
stimmen zum klubobmann also zum chef der
christlich sozialen partei im parlament
gewählt und die stimmen die jetzt
sozusagen hochgespielt werden dass da
eine laut landeshauptmann oder der
andere etwas gesagt hat ich hatte auch
persönlich kontakt mit diesen
landeshauptleuten vergleich mit dem
deutschen ministerpräsidenten
das stimmt so nicht es gibt eine
unglaubliche geschlossenheit die hat
sich schon das ganze wochenende bewährt
in der partei zwischen landeshauptleuten
den bünden und den abgeordneten wenn
jetzt weitere dinge raus kommen weitere
chat nachrichten auskommen wenn es
möglicherweise sogar eine anklage geben
könnte ist sebastian kurz dann noch als
europäischer zu halten also ganz offen
das sind sehr hypothetische fragen wir
sind jetzt gerade durch eine besonders
schwierige situation in diesem land
gegangen wir hatten wirklich große
innenpolitische turbulenten turbulenzen
an sozusagen zurück tung des
vertrauensverhältnisses innerhalb der
koalition allein dass wir heute wieder
ministerin zusammengekommen sind
ökosoziale steuerreform geschlossen
haben das budget ist ein extra
beschlossen signalisiert wir sind jetzt
wieder handlungsfähig und
handlungswillig und alle anderen sind
hypothetische natur meine aufgabe das
ist meine hauptaufgabe momentan ist
sozusagen dieses schiff das in starke
turbulenzen gekommen ist ins schlingern
gekommen ist es ist nicht gekannt hat
und jetzt müssen wir kurs halten sie
sagen kurs halten politisch hat sie mit
sebastian kurz
das thema migration verbunden schon im
außenministerium haben sie dann mit
ihnen zusammengearbeitet
sie planen eine reise nach brüssel wird
das auch ein thema sein für 7
migrationen was werden sie dort große
sagen wir haben eine vielfalt von themen
ist natürlich auch sozusagen mein
antrittsbesuch und ich habe ganz bewusst
brüssel das erste auslands destination
morgen gewählt dass ich zum wir sind
europäischen rates sah michael so
kommissionspräsidenten von der leyen
gehe und ich bin ja selber jemand der
viele viele jahre
cdu themen befasst diese ich habe in
brüssel ausgearbeitet damals und das ist
sicher einer der schwerpunkte die ich
haben werde in meiner arbeit der wärme
die aktuellen themen die auf der tages
auf der europäischen stehen besprechen
und ich gehe davon aus dass eines der
großen zum beispiel sein wird die
pandemie noch haben wir sie nicht im
rückspiegel auch wie wir diesen
wirtschaftlichen aufschwung in den
europäischen ländern spüren wir den
unterstützen können klimawandel
natürlich das fett 50 5 programm also da
gibt es eine ganze reihe an themen und
migration ist und bleibt einer der ganz
großen herausforderungen für den
europäischen kontinent und das wird auch
in den nächsten jahren nicht weggehen
der flüchtlingsstrom aus afghanistan
nimmt er dazu bleiben sie bei ihrer
haltung dass die niemanden aufnehmen
wollen weiter also noch einmal wir haben
ich habe das wiederholt gesagt wir unser
hauptziel ist momentan die evakuierungen
der menschen die entweder russische
staatsbürgerschaft haben oder einen
aufenthaltstitel in österreich aber ja
wir wollen nichts weiter migranten
aufnehmen aus afghanistan wir haben die
viertgrößte kommune das wissen die
meisten menschen nicht wir haben pro
kopf die viertgrößte community an
afghanischen staatsbürger weltweit also
den registern iran dann kommt eine lange
pause und dann schweden und österreich
also sie genau so herzlos wie sowas in
kurzen sich herzlos ich bin überhaupt
nicht herzlos österreich ist ein bild
über die maßen solidarischen team
zusammen haben wir haben seit 2005 10
über 200.000 menschen hier gehabt also
dass uns zu sagen wir sind nicht
solidarisch wir leisten tagtäglich wir
haben jetzt auch für afghanistan das
größte soforthilfe programm auf die
beine gestellt
820 millionen euro immerhin im vergleich
hat deutschland wenn ich richtig
informiert bin 100 millionen die
kommission 300 millionen also das ist
sehr vergleichbar und ich glaube da
mangelnde solidarität oder so zu tun als
könnte man solidarität indem nur so
beweisen dass man menschen aufnimmt
halte ich für verfehlt ich glaube dass
unser ziel sein muss jetzt afghanistan
zu stabilisieren und vor allem das
umfeld auch zu stabilisieren die
diskussion an die ich hatte zum beispiel
mit dem außenminister des iraks vor
wenigen tagen noch war sozusagen passt
bitte dass europäer aufpasste signale
sendet damit es eben nicht zu
migrationsströmen kommen kommt vor zwei
wochen hatten wir auch die urheber kommt
verrät sie sich in allem ein zittern
wenn man jetzt sozusagen sagen wir
wollen jetzt alle rausholen das eher der
glaube ich der falsche zugang unser ziel
muss sein vor ort zu helfen das tun wir
es sind die un- organisationen auch noch
präsent world food program uhren hcr
internationales komitee des roten
kreuzes die sind doch hinweggegangen die
waren doch schon in der vergangenheit
auch in jenen regionen präsent die
unterteile wann kontrolle war ja wir
haben momentan ein problem wir haben
dort ein macht sozusagen machtfaktor mit
dem wir umgehen müssen aber nein wir
werden die menschen in afghanistan nicht
im stich lassen können und das halte ich
für die richtige politik und als letzter
satz noch
flüchtlingshochkommissar filippo grandi
hat selber weil er eine geberkonferenz
geht wir müssen jetzt vor ort helfen
weil neben migrationsströme zu vermeiden
und das halte ich für den richtigen
ansatz
anstatt dass er warten bis sie sich an
europäischen grenzen europas
manifestieren hatten sie schon die
möglichkeit mit deutschen politikern mit
der kanzlerin auch zu sprechen über als
ganz ich freue mich aufs nächste
gespräch noch nicht sieht man die
angelobung ist 48 stunden vorbei ich
hatte schon die gelegenheit mit ein oder
andere nachbar premierminister zu
sprechen ich freue mich auch dass sie
hat ja öffentlich gratuliert er noch
hatte ich nicht die gelegenheit wir sind
in einer situation haben sie die ganze
und freut sich dass du warst ein
kunstwerk ist ja nicht so als freunde
das ist keine frage die sich mir stellt
und ich werde auf jeden fall die
zusammenarbeit mit mit ihr und natürlich
auch mit ihrem nachfolger suchen sie
haben im mai die israelische flagge vom
außenministerium gehisst und damit
empörung in teheran ausgelöst in der
iranischen hauptstadt stehen sie genauso
zum jüdischen staat ihr vorgänger so war
es der kurz absolut das ist auch so eine
politik die wir gemeinsam entwickelt
haben das ist für mich sogar ganz
wesentlich ich glaube dass wir hier auch
aufgrund der höchste schon vergangenheit
eine besondere verantwortung haben aber
es kommt noch ein elemente zu israel ist
eine liberale demokratie im nahen osten
das gehört eigentlich gehört zu gleichen
werte familie wie wir und wir müssen uns
nur bewusst sein dass die die länder die
unsere unsere lebensmodell teil mit
gewaltenteilung rechtsstaatlichkeit
demokratie meinungsfreiheit
medienfreiheit und so weiter wir sind
nur noch 25 prozent aller mitgestalten
und da müssen wir schauen dass auch in
kenntnis der wissen wir sind eigentlich
in einer zunehmenden aggressiven wenn
man so wie die wettbewerbssituation mit
anderen lebensmodellen und meine politik
sowohl das aus und nächstes werde ich
als bundeskanzler auch fortführen ich
will einer politik wo bei der kinder
aber meine zukünftigen vielleicht ein
krieg hinter in einer welt aufwachsen wo
meinungsfreiheit versammlungsfreiheit
religions- verhält und dann müssen wir
ganz genau wissen mit wem wir
zusammenstehen mit wem nicht sie haben
bereits angesprochen die ökosoziale
steuerreform die sie jetzt angeschoben
haben als österreichische regierung wie
in deutschland hören immer
steuersenkungen sprechen ist kein geld
da warum geht bei ihnen was bei uns
nicht geht das müssen sie den deutschen
finanzminister fallen immer wieder
schafft österreich darf dieser klage wir
haben wir haben natürlich einerseits
haben wir enorm viel geld in die hand
genommen während der pandemie bekämpfen
wir haben glaube ich im weltweiten
vergleich habe einer der staaten die das
größte paket auf den weg gebracht hat um
die wirtschaft zu unterstützen diese
wirklich herausfordern zeit es hat sich
als richtig herausgestellt
wir sind eigentlich was den arbeitsmarkt
betrifft wieder dort wo wir 2009 10 war
wir haben einen einem
wirtschaftswachstum zwischen vier und
fünf prozent das heißt diese dass man in
krisenzeiten geld in die hand nimmt und
sozusagen zyklisch arbeit und dann wenn
es gut geht wieder spart das hat sich
als richtig erweisen und das schafft
auch freiräume und wir hoffen sogar dass
er bis zum ende der finanzbehörde bis
2025 wieder ein strukturelles
nulldefizit haben werden und auch bei
der schuldenquote schuldenquote wieder
dort sein werden siege sprechen 2009/10
sprechen das defizit an große debatten
gibt es europa möglicherweise auch eben
mit olaf scholz der kanzler in
deutschland werden könnte um die frage
der gemeinschaften schulden haftung wie
also dass wir hatten die diskussion
schon sehr heftig im zusammenhang mit
den sogenannten recovery fonds ich
glaube da müssen wir sehr aufpassen was
wir hier für signale senden es ist noch
weiterhin so dass jeder staat selber
seine eigene fiskalpolitik in
wirklichkeit betreibt und sein budget
aufstellt und eine situation wo wir
sozusagen die politik anderer staaten
mittragen würden durch unsere
steuerzahler sich dann in österreich ich
glaube
ich bin nicht jemand der in
verhandlungen reingeht oder ex ante nein
sagt ich möchte mal die argumente der
gegenseite anhören dass ich sozusagen
diplomatin mir wenn man so will aber ich
habe eine sehr klare position dass wir
eine transferunion nicht wollen scheint
weg zum abschluss was glauben sie wie
lange werden sie hier kanzler bleiben
wie landeten sie hier im kanzleramt sein
ich bin am montag angelobt worden wir
haben eine legislaturperiode wir haben
ein regierungsprogramm und das habe ich
die absicht auch durchzuführen und diese
phase auch hier meine verantwortung weiß
also dann noch fast drei jahre ja ich
meine man kann in der politik wir alle
haben keine kristallkugel und und
wechsel ist teile demokratie habe ich ja
selber gab es am eigenen leib sozusagen
erfahren das ist ein abend dass ich
wieder angestrebt habe noch gewollt habe
ursprünglich also aber ja jetzt gilt es
einmal stabilität sicherheit substanz
arbeit dafür werde ich versuchen zu
sorgen nach besten wissen wir wissen
gemeinsam mit dem koalitionspartner und
wir haben ein programm ohne
legislaturperiode vormals ganz klar egal
wie lange sie hier sind wird nach in
sebastian kurz wieder einzeln ganz offen
das sind hypothetische fragen ich habe
deinen satz den englischen satz gern mit
cross bridge im register herzlichen dank
alexander schallenberg für das gespräch
und wir wünschen ihnen bei der schweren
aufgabe viel glück und damit zurück nach
berlin
[Musik]